Hello, this is Captain J.B. up here in Skycopter 4.
What are we looking at today?
Well, there's a little bit of a congestion over there.
Jay-B, you lost your license.
Bring the chopper back.
You lost your life.
You're not supposed to.
The world's going to switch other programming here.
你好，我是天空直升机4号的J.B.机长。我们今天在看什么呢？嗯，那边有点拥堵。Jay-B，你驾照被吊销了。把直升机开回来。你丢了性命。你不应该在那儿。世界要切换到其他节目了。
Welcome to Smartless.
Doesn't Jason kind of look like he just woke up?
He just woke up.
He's going to have a bowl of cereal and watch cartoons.
I've had cereal.
I've had my granola, my sugar-free gluten-free granola,
with my unsweetened almond milk.
I want to just blow my brains out.
欢迎来到Smartless。Jason看起来是不是像刚睡醒？他确实刚睡醒。他打算吃碗麦片粥，看会儿动画片。我吃过麦片了。我吃了我的格兰诺拉麦片，无糖无麸质的格兰诺拉麦片，配上我的无糖杏仁奶。我真想一头撞死。
That sounds like, Jesus.
It's halfway describing it.
It's just terrible.
You're finally getting it.
Fuck.
My sugar-free, urbamate, fucking.
It looks like urine.
听起来，天哪。这简直是描述了一半。太可怕了。你终于明白了。你终于明白了。该死。我的无糖，马黛茶，该死的。看起来像尿一样。
It's not worth it, right, Will?
Didn't you say I was going to, I was going to die without a whole lot of water retention?
but it'll all be young.
And remember, and the whole idea is that I was going to be
at your bedside eating a Sunday with 30 years to go.
Right, and me and my wooden teeth
will be sitting in a casket.
J.B., you got like a really, like you got like a sort of sexy,
这不值得，对吧，Will？你不是说如果我不摄入大量水分，我就会死吗？但一切都会变年轻。记住，整个想法是我要在你床边吃圣代，还有30年要过。对，我和我的木头假牙会坐在棺材里。J.B.，你有一种非常，就像有一种性感，
like post-sex look.
That's what I'm saying.
Right?
Well, does the hand count?
Oh, no.
No, I don't do that.
Talk to the hand.
Keep talking to the hand.
那种事后的样子。我就是这个意思。对吧？嗯，手算吗？哦，不。不，我不做那个。跟手说去吧。继续跟手说去吧。
I just, I'm just, I was telling Sean, I just did some reading, that's all.
This is just me and reading, reading, reading.
This is reading for the, for the movie you're doing, yeah?
For maybe what might follow.
You know, we, we, you know, we're hustlers, you know, us people.
We're constantly getting hired and fired, and you've got to try to build a bridge to the next check.
That's right.
继续跟手说去吧。我只是，我只是，我刚才在告诉Sean，我只是读了点东西，仅此而已。这就是我和阅读，阅读，阅读。这是为你正在做的电影做的阅读，对吧？为了可能接下来的事情。你知道，我们，我们，你知道，我们是拼命三郎，你知道，我们这些人。我们不断地被雇佣和解雇，你必须努力架起通往下一张支票的桥梁。没错。
Always.
Yep.
I know.
You're so exhausted.
Stop.
How about we just stop?
Let's just stop.
You know, because you know what?
总是这样。是的。我知道。你太累了。停下。我们要不就停下吧？我们停下吧。你知道，因为你知道吗？
I hear it from you if we stopped.
Let's just chat.
We'll just chat once a week.
You know, and we don't have to do any reading, and we don't have to do any, you know, getting up at crazy hours and being away from our families.
Oh, my God.
Your voice is kind of worbly.
Well, I'm here and lonely in New York.
I know.
如果我们停下，我会从你那儿听到的。我们只是聊天吧。我们每周聊一次。你知道，我们不必做任何阅读，也不必做任何，你知道，在疯狂的时间起床，远离我们的家人。哦，天哪。你的声音有点颤抖。嗯，我在这儿，在纽约很孤独。我知道。
I'm going to be there soon, J.B.
and for the first
couple of weeks
I'm going to be across the street from you
until I move in to my place.
Yeah?
Yeah.
I'm going to be right there
我很快就会到那儿，J.B.，前几周我会住在你街对面，直到我搬进我的住处。是吗？是的。我就在那儿。
so I'm going to come
and I'll come and spoon you at night.
I'm there in June, late June.
We're good.
We're going to be going to.
So, yeah, J.B., but I'm going to...
I knew that was coming.
See, that's what's generous about us three.
所以我打算过去，晚上我会去抱抱你。我六月在那儿，六月下旬。我们很好。我们要去。所以，是的，J.B.，但我打算……我知道那要来了。你看，这就是我们三个人慷慨的地方。
We each take turns.
It's setting each other up to hurt our own feelings.
Now, J.B., do you like being isolated like that
by yourself there and all that stuff?
I do.
You know, I was thinking the other day that I have lived in a number of these temporary situations
because of work in various places around.
Yeah.
我们轮流来。这是在互相设置陷阱来伤害我们自己的感情。现在，J.B.，你喜欢那样独自被隔离在那儿，还有所有那些东西吗？我喜欢。你知道，前几天我在想，因为工作的原因，我在各地住过很多这种临时住所。是的。
And I was actually, I was thinking, well, I'm kind of surprised it.
I've made a friend of that and I'm kind of comfortable with that because you know, you know me.
I'm so, I'm so locked and committed and comfortable in my cave at home.
Like, I don't, I don't leave.
But you create a cave.
You create a cave everywhere you.
It's true.
I'm good about like immediately.
我当时其实在想，嗯，我有点惊讶。我对此交了个朋友，我对此感到很舒服，因为你知道，你了解我。我在家里的洞穴里是如此，如此锁定、投入和舒适。就像，我不，我不离开。但你创造了一个洞穴。你在任何地方都创造一个洞穴。这是真的。我擅长于立即。
Every time you get into rental,
I remember in Atlanta when I was living
in that building underneath you,
you had your cave there with your couch
and your thing, right?
Yeah, the couch has got to be in a situation
where I can be laying down
perpendicular.
每次你住进出租屋，我记得在亚特兰大时，我住在你楼下的那栋楼里，你有你的洞穴，有你的沙发和你的东西，对吧？是的，沙发必须处于一种我可以垂直躺下的位置。
Yeah, so that I'm looking
across my body,
over my feet, right to the TV.
The couch is, again, perpendicular
to the television.
Yeah.
And then...
If I've got that, I'm comfy.
是的，这样我就可以看着我的身体，越过我的脚，直视电视。沙发，再次强调，与电视垂直。是的。然后……如果我有那个，我就很舒服。
Remember on tour, every hotel
immediately
couch.
Right in the corner.
And then the TV on,
Jay B Wood.
Right on the corner.
And then you come out to Long Island,
记得在巡演时，每家酒店立即找沙发。就在角落里。然后电视打开，Jay B Wood。就在角落里。然后你来到长岛，
you get to my house.
Everybody's outside and J.B.'s on the couch.
I know,
but then unfortunately,
that's usually the host's spot.
That's your spot.
No, no, because remember I had those two.
You do the corner.
你到了我家。每个人都在外面，而J.B.在沙发上。我知道，但不幸的是，那通常是主人的位置。那是你的位置。不，不，因为记得我有那两个。你占角落。
I have those two corners.
Yeah, you do the other,
why do you do that?
Well, but every single, yeah,
and every single time you come over here, Jay,
you got your spot on the couch,
exactly how you just described.
And I feel bad that this must be,
我有那两个角落。是的，你占另一个，你为什么要那样做？嗯，但是每一次，是的，每一次你到这儿来，Jay，你都有你在沙发上的位置，完全就像你刚才描述的那样。我感到很抱歉，这一定是，
this is the prime spot.
Sean, I'm sorry I'm in your spot.
Will, I'm sorry I'm in your spot.
You're not.
You don't.
You don't care.
Nobody, you got, that's your spot.
But I do the same.
这是黄金位置。Sean，抱歉我占了你的位置。Will，抱歉我占了你的位置。你没有。你不在乎。没人，你有，那是你的位置。但我做同样的事。
Like last summer somebody came in and we were watching soccer.
And Bradley and I were in that same configuration.
And we were both asleep.
And my brother came in.
We were both on the couch midday.
Quick.
Quick, quick.
Chuck, Chuck, Chuck, Chuck, Chuck.
就像去年夏天有人进来，我们在看足球。Bradley和我在同样的配置里。我们都睡着了。我哥哥进来了。我们俩都在沙发上，中午。快。快，快，Chuck，Chuck，Chuck，Chuck，Chuck。
Okay, good.
Wait, but Jason.
Chuck Arnette.
Quick shout out to Chuck Arne.
Hey, Charles.
Charles.
Wait, but, Chase, I just need to know that you.
好的，很好。等等，但是Jason。Chuck Arnette。快速向Chuck Arne致敬。嘿，Charles。Charles。Charles。等等，但是，Chase，我只需要知道你。
You don't get, so after a while of being isolated,
don't you miss people and the opposite of that?
I would if in those situations, when I'm isolated by myself,
in a foreign city, I'm not spending 12 hours during the day
with hundreds of new people and my new family on each one of those.
Right.
So, again, it's that black-white situation.
Are we now able to, are we allowed to talk about your new family?
你没有，所以被隔离了一段时间后，你不怀念人们和相反的情况吗？如果是在那些情况下，当我独自被隔离在外国城市时，我白天不会和数百个新人和我的新家人在一起。对。所以，再次强调，这是那种非黑即白的情况。我们现在能，我们被允许谈论你的新家人吗？
Because I didn't know if the public knew about this or whatever.
That one, not that one.
This is exciting news that we're getting to do it.
We've just scooped Card 11 at TMZ.
With three children.
Yeah, it's amazing.
I'll tell you what's amazing.
Oh, really?
因为我不知道公众是否知道这件事什么的。那个，不是那个。这是我们能做的令人兴奋的消息。我们刚刚在TMZ抢先报道了Card 11。有三个孩子。是的，太棒了。我告诉你什么才是棒的。哦，真的吗？
Our surprise guest, he is one of the greats when it comes to comedy.
Uh-huh.
He got his start on Mad TV.
He's been in over 100 episodes.
He's been in so many things that we love.
These days, he's in a show that he created with Mindickely.
that's coming back for season two called Running Point.
But he's also lately been known as one of the breakout,
我们的惊喜嘉宾，他是喜剧界的伟人之一。嗯哼。他从Mad TV开始。他出演了100多集。他出演了太多我们喜爱的作品。这些天，他在一个他与Mindickely共同创作的节目中，该节目即将回归第二季，名为Running Point。但他最近也被称为突破性人物之一，
amazing, hilarious stars of Apple TVs, the studio.
Guys, it's our friend.
It's Mike Barrett-all!
First, can I just shout out Chuck Arnett real quick?
Is that cool?
Of course.
Chuckie.
It's my guy.
Apple TV《The Studio》中令人惊叹、搞笑的明星。伙计们，是我们的朋友。是Mike Barrett-all！首先，我能快速向Chuck Arnett致敬吗？可以吗？当然。Chuckie。那是我的伙计。
Yeah, yeah.
My guy.
Oh, Ike, this is great.
This is this, now this is a guest, Will?
Yeah.
I know.
This is a guest.
This is one of the guys.
是的，是的。我的伙计。哦，Ike，这太棒了。这是，现在这是一个嘉宾，Will？是的。我知道。这是一个嘉宾。这是我们的人之一。
I'm so glad you're here.
I was thinking about this morning.
I was pouring myself a coffee this morning,
and I said to myself, I said,
Oh, great, fill us in.
What did you?
You put some sugar in it too?
这是我们的人之一。我很高兴你在这儿。我今天早上在想这个。我今天早上给自己倒咖啡，我对自己说，我说，哦，太棒了，告诉我们。你加了什么？你也加了糖吗？
No, Steve, yeah.
Well, if I'm being real, truvia,
and then some ripple half and half.
Because it's pea-based.
It's so good.
Donnery.
It's pea-based?
Gonderry.
不，Steve，是的。嗯，如果我说实话，Truvia，然后是一些Ripple半对半。因为它是豌豆基的。太好了。Donnery。它是豌豆基的？Gonderry。
Ripple?
You're talking about cheap liquor?
Yeah, so.
And it's pee-based.
Like, you and I,
You and I met, I don't know, it is P-Base.
It's made in Canada, by the way, don't you know, eh?
What is that right?
Ripple？你在说廉价酒吗？是的，所以。而且它是豌豆基的。就像，你和我，你和我认识，我不知道，它是豌豆基的。它是加拿大制造的，顺便说一句，你不知道吗，嗯？那是对的吗？
Hey, hey, bud, I got some P's here.
Should we make some half and half?
Give her.
Fucking letter ripple.
Fucking giver, bud.
Who is that right, eh?
Wait, Ike, where are you?
嘿，嘿，伙计，我这儿有些豌豆。我们应该做些半对半吗？给它。该死的Ripple。给它。该死的给它，伙计。那是谁，嗯？等等，Ike，你在哪儿？
So, I just want to say, before we find out where you are,
Ike, we've known each other for about 20 years.
And I was thinking, and I was thinking,
Ike is one of those guys
you're always happy to see
in person
on the screen
doing stuff
所以，我只想说，在我们找出你在哪儿之前，Ike，我们认识大约20年了。我在想，我在想，Ike是那种你总是很高兴在屏幕上看到他做事情的人。
it's a rare no you're one of the rare ones
is there something darker there that you've kept hidden
from let's talk about it
first time my dad beat the hell out of me
I was six
hey guys I just say first I'm a huge fan of this show
I'm a massive fan I've listened to
I think every episode so I really
这是一个罕见的，不，你是罕见的人之一，有什么更黑暗的东西是你一直隐藏起来的吗？让我们谈谈吧。我爸爸第一次狠狠地揍我时，我六岁。嘿，伙计们，我先说，我是这个节目的超级粉丝。我是个铁杆粉丝。我想我听了每一集，所以我真的
this is my plan to
is to really...
What's your favorite?
What's your least favorite?
No, kidding.
Of the three of us.
We can't name names.
You can't name names.
这是我的计划，真的……你最喜欢哪一集？你最不喜欢哪一集？不，开玩笑的。我们三个之中。我们不能点名。你不能点名。
Last time I saw Ike in person,
I surprised him on a morning.
He was staying at Amy's apartment in New York
and I was coming to pick up a jacket or something.
Can we stop there?
Yeah, yeah.
No, that's not breaking news.
It's not breaking news.
上次我见到Ike本人，我早上给了他一个惊喜。他住在Amy在纽约的公寓里，我当时去拿一件夹克什么的。我们能停在那儿吗？是的，是的。不，那不是突发新闻。那不是突发新闻。
They're not taking...
Amy and Ike are not together anymore.
No, no, not anymore.
She let me her apartment while I was doing a Broadway show.
He was doing a Broadway show.
He was the greatest thing ever to stay in that place.
My God.
So,
他们没有……Amy和Ike不再在一起了。不，不，不再在一起了。我演百老汇剧时她把公寓借给我。他当时在演百老汇剧。住在那儿真是太棒了。天哪。所以，
so Ike was doing...
Ike was doing this play on Broadway.
Yes.
And you were kind of right in the middle?
Were you just starting or forget?
We were right in the middle when I saw you.
What was it?
Yeah, I was Chicago.
所以Ike当时在做……Ike在百老汇演这部戏。是的。你当时正好在中间？你是刚开始还是忘了？我们正好在中间，当我见到你时。是什么？是的，我是芝加哥。
I was playing Roxy Hart.
It was...
I got blasted by the critics,
and rightfully so, quite frankly.
They didn't buy it, huh?
They didn't like it.
They didn't like my take on it.
Because I played it...
我扮演Roxy Hart。那是……我被评论家痛骂，坦率地说，理应如此。他们不买账，是吧？他们不喜欢。他们不喜欢我对它的诠释。因为我演得……
Just as like a bro.
Yeah, you followed Cheetah Rivera.
Yeah, it didn't catch.
You didn't try to do anything feminine at all with it?
No, I just had a total bro take?
Yeah, no, like, yeah, I reached for the gun.
Now, Ike, have you done a bunch of theater?
Or was that just the one pop there, Chicago?
就像个兄弟。是的，你追随了Cheetah Rivera。是的，没赶上。你根本没尝试做任何女性化的东西吗？不，我只是完全采取了兄弟的演法？是的，不，就像，是的，我伸手去拿枪。现在，Ike，你演过很多戏剧吗？还是那只是芝加哥那一次？
I started with, you know, improv in Chicago back in the day,
but that was my first time doing the Great White Way.
Okay, okay to say that?
Did people come backstage and visit you after the show?
Oh, no, we're not.
Hang on, shut up, shot up.
We're creating a consensus here.
Did people come and say about how do you after the show?
我开始于，你知道，芝加哥的即兴表演，但那是我第一次走上百老汇。好的，可以这么说吗？演出结束后有人去后台看你吗？哦，不，我们不是。等等，闭嘴，闭嘴。我们在这儿达成共识。演出结束后有人去说怎么做吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And did you enjoy that?
I did, yeah.
I mean, we had friends come backstage, but then you do the stage door,
which is crazy.
It's called Act three.
Act three, you go out and you're schmooze and you sign autographs and take selfies,
and that really touched me, I thought.
是的，是的，是的。你喜欢那样吗？我喜欢，是的。我的意思是，我们有朋友去后台，但然后你做舞台门，那很疯狂。这叫第三幕。第三幕，你出去，你寒暄，你签名，拍自拍，那真的触动了我，我想。
And you give it to other people because you do it for them
because it's not all about you, right?
Go ahead, Jason.
It's not all about me.
Hold, Sean, why wouldn't we call that act four outside?
Are we talking about a typical three-ad structure?
Because usually things are in two acts.
Yeah, aren't they?
你把它给了别人，因为你为他们做，因为这不仅仅是关于你，对吧？继续，Jason。这不仅仅是关于我。等等，Sean，为什么我们不把外面叫第四幕？我们在谈论典型的三幕结构吗？因为通常事情是两幕。是的，不是吗？
There we go.
Usually it's a three-act plays.
Well, in plays and musicals, there's two.
God, I got to get you the internet.
Just because of the, what you can call it,
the halftime there?
The intermission?
Is there any show during halftime?
这就对了。通常是三幕剧。嗯，在戏剧和音乐剧中，有两幕。天哪，我得给你弄个互联网。只是因为，你怎么称呼它，那里的中场休息？幕间休息？中场休息时有节目吗？
Hang on, I'm gonna do everybody,
Jason, I'm about to do your favor.
Today's guest, it's Ike Barrenholz.
Hey-ah!
Good quick edit point there.
We can just take it all of that.
No, you like people coming back,
because Jason's right, we are trying to figure out,
等等，我要帮大家一个忙，Jason，我要帮你的忙。今天的嘉宾，是Ike Barrenholtz。嘿啊！那儿有个很好的快速剪辑点。我们可以把那部分都剪掉。不，你喜欢人们回来，因为Jason是对的，我们正在试图弄清楚，
this is a long-term study that we're doing over here at Smart.
I hear that you are supposed, if you are somewhat famous,
you are somewhat obligated to go backstage afterwards,
regardless of whether you know anyone in the cast,
and go, you know, say hi to them and tell them what you thought about the show.
And I've just thought that that would be presumptuous
and also would delay those actors getting home and resting.
Ike, thoughts?
这是我们Smart正在进行的长期研究。我听说，如果你有点名气，你就有义务在演出结束后去后台，不管你是否认识剧组里的任何人，去，你知道，跟他们打招呼，告诉他们你对演出的看法。我一直认为那会很自以为是，而且会耽误那些演员回家休息。Ike，怎么看？
It really depends on the celebrity.
Like, for instance, Jason, if you were there and you came backstage,
it would be so exciting.
We would take pictures.
Everyone would be excited.
But if like, I don't know.
Oh, careful.
Rob Schneider showed up.
这真的取决于名人。比如，Jason，如果你在那儿，你去了后台，那会非常令人兴奋。我们会拍照。每个人都会很兴奋。但如果像，我不知道。哦，小心。Rob Schneider出现了。
I'm just using a name.
I'm throwing out there.
Shots fired.
But like, you know what I mean?
There's someone who was like,
oh, we've got to stay behind for a person X, Y, or Z.
Right.
Yeah.
我只是随便用个名字。我只是抛出来。开火了。但就像，你知道我的意思吗？有人说，哦，我们得为了X、Y或Z留下来。对。是的。
So it goes both ways.
How fun would it be, like if you were backstage
and all of a sudden, Jason came back and he just actually said it on the night.
He just said, hey, I'm famous.
So I'm coming back to.
So let's talk, and where should we sit?
Because I've got notes.
Do you want to just go back into your dressing room?
所以这是双向的。如果你在后台，突然Jason回来了，他真的在当晚说了出来，那会有多有趣？他只是说，嘿，我很出名。所以我回来也是。所以我们谈谈，我们该坐哪儿？因为我有笔记。你想直接回你的更衣室吗？
Is it locked?
Just famous guy to famous guy, you know?
I know what you were going for, but let me tell you what's reading.
Well, you can go ahead and take the wink out of it.
That would be, that's a lot.
That's a lot.
Now, I was sitting about mid-house, and I really wasn't feeling there in the third act.
You were mid-house?
锁了吗？只是名人对名人，你知道？我知道你要表达什么，但让我告诉你什么是阅读。嗯，你可以继续把那个眨眼去掉。那会是，那很多。那很多。现在，我坐在剧场中间，我在第三幕真的没感觉。你坐在中间？
I hate famous, Jason.
I hate famous Jason so much.
Wait, the fact that you have.
at the ready, I know what you were going for, but here's what's reading.
Like, you have that in your head ready to go.
Well, I'm getting ready to direct over here.
You know, I'm in prep.
Yeah, he's in prep.
我讨厌出名的Jason。我太讨厌出名的Jason了。等等，事实上你有。准备好了，我知道你要表达什么，但这是阅读。就像，你脑子里有那个准备好了。嗯，我正准备在这儿导演。你知道，我在准备中。是的，他在准备中。
I saw a video of J.B. and our buddy, Sam Rockwell, at the Knicks game.
And it was footage at MSG and they're walking.
And Jason's talked to him, it looked like he was giving him notes on the way to their seats.
We haven't started shooting yet.
And if I'm Rockwell, I'm like, hey, man, I just came to me.
watch the fucking next game.
I know what you're planning on doing.
Let me tell you how that's probably going to read.
我看到一段J.B.和我们的哥们Sam Rockwell在尼克斯比赛的视频。那是MSG的镜头，他们正在走。Jason在跟他说话，看起来他是在去座位的路上给他提意见。我们还没开始拍摄。如果我是Rockwell，我会说，嘿，伙计，我只是来看该死的尼克斯比赛。我知道你打算做什么。让我告诉你那可能会怎么读。
And Sandy's so nice, he probably just took it, but God, what exhausting.
Shout out, before we're done here, shout out to the nice folks over there at MSG for accommodating
me.
They are the best.
They're the best.
Front row center.
Thank you, Trey, and the group over there.
It's just in those Knicks, they brought it home that night.
Sandy人真好，他可能只是接受了，但天哪，多累人啊。致敬，在我们结束之前，向MSG那些好心人致敬，感谢他们照顾我。他们是最棒的。他们是最棒的。前排中心。谢谢Trey和那里的团队。只是在那些尼克斯队，那天晚上他们赢了。
They're a classy organization.
I don't know when this is airing, but it's a good time.
They're looking good.
That's what, Sean's been saying this.
all season.
Yeah.
So.
Just on a loop.
他们是一个有格调的组织。我不知道这是什么时候播出的，但这是一个好时机。他们看起来不错。这就是，Sean一直说的。整个赛季。是的。所以。只是在循环。
What a fucking loop of up.
Are you guys talking about Knicks?
Yeah.
Oh, here we go.
Spell it.
Spell it, Sean.
Spell it real quick.
K.
真是个该死的循环。你们在谈论尼克斯吗？是的。哦，开始了。拼出来。拼出来，Sean。快点拼出来。K。
K.N.
And what's it short for?
Nicaragua.
Nickerbockers.
Oh, is Nicaragua.
Oh, is it really Nicarbocker?
Yeah, it is.
Higher, higher, Sean.
K.N. 那是什么的缩写？尼加拉瓜。尼克博克。哦，是尼加拉瓜。哦，真的是尼克博克吗？是的，是。更高，更高，Sean。
Hey, now, listen.
It's it really Nicarbock.
Listen.
Are we?
Higher and just a dash more gay.
Okay.
And still rolling?
嘿，现在，听着。真的是尼克博克吗？听着。我们是吗？更高，再多一点同性恋色彩。好的。还在录吗？好的。
Is it really?
Nickerbocker?
Welcome Ike Baranholtz to the show.
Welcome to the show.
It's Ike Barronholz.
Another cut point.
Wow.
真的是吗？真的是吗？尼克博克？欢迎Ike Baranholtz来到节目。欢迎来到节目。是Ike Barronholz。另一个剪辑点。哇。
Hey, now listen, I was going to have a different intro for Sean.
But I was going to open with because Sean, because I,
Ike, I'm from Chicago.
And obviously the question is, I'm from Glen Ellen.
Oh, Jillis.
I'm on Glen Ellen.
Have you been to Glen Ellen?
I have been at Glenn Allen.
嘿，现在听着，我本来要给Sean一个不同的介绍。但我本来要开场，因为Sean，因为我，Ike，我来自芝加哥。显然问题是，我来自Glen Ellen。哦，Jillis。我在Glen Ellen。你去过Glen Ellen吗？我去过Glenn Allen。
I've been all the Glens.
A lot of glens in Chicago.
Glenn View.
Have you ever been to...
Portilloes.
I've been to be Pertillo's many a time, my friend.
Chocolate cake shake.
They have a milk shake where they dump a big slice of cake.
我去过所有的Glens。芝加哥有很多Glens。Glenn View。你去过……Portilloes吗？我去过Pertillo's很多次，我的朋友。巧克力奶昔。他们有一种奶昔，把一大块蛋糕倒进去。
Jason said in Ozark, chocolate cake shake from Pertilis,
and he doesn't remember that.
Catherine Hahn, by the way, is watching Ozark now.
The best.
Oh my God, she just sent me a text yesterday as a matter of fact.
That's weird.
You must be working with her.
So she sent me to tell you said, hey, I'm really embarrassingly late on this,
Jason在Ozark里说，Pertilis的巧克力奶昔，他不记得了。顺便说一句，Catherine Hahn现在正在看Ozark。最棒的。哦，天哪，事实上她昨天刚给我发了条短信。真奇怪。你一定在和她合作。所以她发短信告诉我，嘿，我在这件事上真的很尴尬地迟到了，
but you're great in Ozark or something like that.
Who says that?
Catherine Hahn, the greatest love of my life.
And I said, I was just so excited that she's seeing it for the first time.
I was just like, I was so tempted to say, what's your favorite part?
Yeah, she would come to set and she's like, Ozark is amazing.
We're like, we know.
I wonder why she started watching that.
但你在Ozark里很棒之类的。谁会这么说？Catherine Hahn，我生命中最伟大的爱。我说，我只是太兴奋了，她第一次看到它。我当时就像，我太想说，你最喜欢哪一部分？是的，她会来片场，她说，Ozark太棒了。我们说，我们知道。我不知道她为什么开始看那个。
I wonder if it.
She must have, she must have tapped.
everything else out.
All her subscriptions
had maxed out
and she found an old
iPad that belonged to a neighbor and it was
loaded up.
我不知道它是否。她一定，她一定把其他一切都看完了。她所有的订阅都用完了，她发现了一个属于邻居的旧iPad，里面装满了。
Han told me a story.
She had
Laura Dern's phone number
and she would text Laura Dern
sometimes and had like a little bit of a texting
relationship with her.
And then when David Lynch
passed away, Han reached out and was like,
Hahn给我讲了一个故事。她有Laura Dern的电话号码，她有时会给Laura Dern发短信，和她有一点短信关系。然后当David Lynch去世时，Hahn联系了她，说，
I'm so sorry about your collaboration.
I know how much he meant to you.
And the person said,
I don't think this is who you think it is.
And it was...
The worst.
Tina Faye Stand-in
from This is where I leave you.
我很抱歉你们的合作。我知道他对你意味着什么。那个人说，我不认为这是你以为的那个人。那是……最糟糕的。Tina Faye在《This is where I leave you》里的替身。
And there's years of texts.
Ten years of text.
Who she thought was Laura Turner.
Just staying in loose, casual contact with over the years.
No fucking way.
Yeah.
Oh, got it.
Wait a minute.
而且有几年的短信。十年的短信。她以为是Laura Turner。多年来一直保持着松散、随意的联系。没门。是的。哦，明白了。等等。
Where are you?
Are you in New York right now?
I'm in London, night.
Here's your proof.
I'm in London.
Look, the bottle lid doesn't come off.
I know.
How annoying was that?
你在哪儿？你现在在纽约吗？我在伦敦，晚上。这是你的证据。我在伦敦。看，瓶盖没掉下来。我知道。那有多烦人？
On all the plastic bottles, they don't come off.
They just hang there.
Is that true?
Yeah.
That's not a bad design idea.
It's kind of smart, actually, if you think about it.
But it's hard to screw it back on.
And then you do sometimes like, yeah.
在所有的塑料瓶上，它们都不会掉下来。它们只是挂在那儿。那是真的吗？是的。那不是个坏设计主意。如果你仔细想想，其实挺聪明的。但很难把它拧回去。然后你有时会像，是的。
I was wondering why you got your mic jacked on your rolling luggage.
Yeah, this is no video?
Is that on your luggage?
Rob was like, you got some books, right?
I was like, no, this hotel room doesn't have any books,
so I have it on my roller bag.
I love you.
You said, wait, wait, it's no video, right?
我一直在想为什么你的麦克风插在你的行李箱上。是的，没有视频？那是在你的行李箱上吗？Rob说，你有几本书，对吧？我说，不，这个酒店房间没有任何书，所以我把它放在我的行李箱上。我爱你。你说，等等，等等，没有视频，对吧？
It's no video.
It is a great composition there with your little frame.
There's one little wheel, bottom left.
Are you shooting the studio over there right now?
Is that what's happening?
We're actually here for the Bafters, mate.
We're going nominated for a bloody Bafta.
Oh, that's great.
没有视频。你那小框架的构图很棒。左下角有一个小轮子。你现在在那儿拍工作室吗？那是怎么回事？我们其实是为了Bafters来的，伙计。我们被提名了一个该死的Bafter。哦，那太棒了。
Congratulations.
Yeah, it's very cool.
It's weird, though.
It's the best foreign.
show. So all the other shows that are nominated, some of them I've heard of, but a lot of them are
like BBC One shows that are like, are you quite through now, sir, you know what I mean?
It's like weird British shows that you don't know in the States.
Well, that's fun. Congrats on the thing. So, so, dude, you've done so much stuff we mentioned.
恭喜。是的，非常酷。不过很奇怪。这是最好的外国。节目。所以所有其他被提名的节目，有些我听说过，但很多是BBC One的节目，就像，先生，你还没说完吗，你知道我的意思吗？就像你在美国不知道的奇怪的英国节目。嗯，那很有趣。恭喜那件事。所以，所以，伙计，你做了很多我们提到的事情。
So let's talk, you did start in Chicago. We're talking about...
Did you grow up in Chicago, I?
Yes, I grew up in Uptown, exactly one mile away from Wrigleyfield.
Oh, wow.
in the city right in the heart of the city right there yeah in the city not some bullshit 80 miles away
you know from Chicago nothing but fucking tire treadmarks all over the road no I used to well
rigley near Wrigley is the is boystown I basically honestly kind of grew up in boys town yeah yeah
all the gay everywhere we would go to the gay parade it's super gay around Wrigley field yeah is that
所以我们谈谈，你确实是在芝加哥开始的。我们在谈论……你在芝加哥长大吗，I？是的，我在Uptown长大，离Wrigleyfield正好一英里。哦，哇。在城市里，就在城市中心。是的，在城市里，不是什么离芝加哥80英里远的废话，你知道，路上全是该死的轮胎痕迹，不，我过去常，嗯，Wrigley附近是Boystown，我基本上老实说是在Boystown长大的，是的，是的，到处都是同性恋，我们会去参加同性恋游行，Wrigley field周围超级同性恋，是的，那是
right yeah yeah yeah we'll be right
back. And now back to the show.
So you grew up in the city
and I know that you, so you're
sort of... Second City and all that.
Yeah, was improv. You kind of,
you started an improv on stage.
Big improv guy. I saw,
真的吗，是的，是的，是的，我们马上回来。现在回到节目。所以你在城市长大，我知道你，所以你有点……Second City什么的。是的，是即兴表演。你有点，你开始在舞台上即兴表演。即兴表演大咖。我看到，
yeah, I, college didn't really work
and then I went to the Improv
Olympics, like 10 year anniversary
show and I saw
Amy Polar, I saw
Adam McKay,
Tim Meadows in particular, was so,
so funny that I was like, I'm going to sign up for
是的，我，大学没怎么成功，然后我去了Improv Olympics，就像10周年纪念演出，我看到了Amy Polar，我看到了Adam McKay，Tim Meadows特别，太，太搞笑了，以至于我当时想，我要报名参加
and I really just immersed myself in that whole...
That's amazing.
The trifecta, the trifecta.
Were there people who were kind of in your year back then,
who you still are work with or tight with?
Like, who else?
Oh, yeah.
I mean, Jack McBrayer is a very dear friend in mind.
我真的沉浸在那个整体中……太棒了。三巨头，三巨头。当时有没有和你同届的人，你现在还在和他们一起工作或关系密切？比如，还有谁？哦，是的。我的意思是，Jack McBrayer是我非常亲爱的朋友。
No, we don't consider him.
You don't really like Jack.
No, when Jack is a person in like Greta.
Yeah, he's not that great.
But like Seth Myers was kind of my generation.
Sedakis was around there.
John Lutz, like that.
Cruz was around there.
不，我们不考虑他。你其实不喜欢Jack。不，当Jack是一个人，像Greta。是的，他没那么好。但像Seth Myers是我那一代的。Sedakis就在那儿。John Lutz，之类的。Cruz就在那儿。
Lutz.
One of the all-time greats.
One of the all-time grades.
Love Lutz.
Yeah, Seth.
I mean, between Second City, UCB and Groundlings, I mean, if there was like a little Olympics going, how do you think those three would do?
Well, there's so much crossover.
Right.
Lutz。史上最伟大的人之一。史上最伟大的人之一。爱Lutz。是的，Seth。我的意思是，在Second City、UCB和Groundlings之间，我的意思是，如果有一个小奥运会，你觉得那三个会怎么样？嗯，有很多交叉。对。
Yeah, there is a lot of crossover now.
I mean, Groundlings is more like I was.
UCB doesn't go back that far, right?
Which is the oldest?
Yeah, like in like 95 or so, Amy and the guys kind of left.
And Matt and Matt and Ian.
So Del Close, he knows this,
Del Close was the guy at Improv Olympic,
是的，现在有很多交叉。我的意思是，Groundlings更像我。UCB没那么久远，对吧？哪个是最古老的？是的，就像95年左右，Amy和那些家伙离开了。Matt和Matt和Ian。所以Del Close，他知道这个，Del Close是Improv Olympic的人，
and they all studied with him, and he was your director.
Was Groundlings or Second City the oldest?
Second City is the oldest.
Second City was like 1962.
Like Ed Asner was in the original Second City.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that goes way back.
他们都跟他学习，他是你们的导演。Groundlings还是Second City最古老？Second City是最古老的。Second City就像1962年。像Ed Asner就在最初的Second City里。哦，哇。是的，是的，是的。所以那追溯到很久以前。
Groundlings, I think, is more like mid-70s hippies.
So, and did you not go, do I have this wrong?
Did you go to Amsterdam?
Sorry, Sean, we're recording something.
Wait one second.
Look at.
This is Favro.
This is at Second City.
Groundlings，我想更像是70年代中期的嬉皮士。所以，你没去，我弄错了吗？你去过阿姆斯特丹？抱歉，Sean，我们在录东西。等一下。看。这是Favro。这是在Second City。
Favro.
That's me right there.
That's Jack McBrayer right next to me.
Wait, were you at a touring company?
No, that was, we just went back for like a, and Ramos, Harold Ramos right there.
And then we just went back for like an anniversary.
But the fact that you said Jack McPrayer or Second City, that's crazy, all those people that came out there, including yourself from that whole troop and all of those things in Chicago, it's just,
It doesn't happen anymore, it feels like.
Favro。那是我。那是我旁边的Jack McBrayer。等等，你在巡回剧团吗？不，那是，我们只是回去参加一个，还有Ramos，Harold Ramos就在那儿。然后我们只是回去参加一个周年纪念。但你提到Jack McPrayer或Second City的事实，那太疯狂了，所有那些从那整个剧团和芝加哥所有那些事情中出来的人，这只是，感觉不再发生了。
The mid-90s improv scene was, it was really fun.
And then I would work at Second City as like a bus boy,
and I would see like Tina when she first started,
like Scott Adtson, Brian Stack, a lot of the, you know, Cohen guys,
Jerry Miner, just amazing killers.
Stack one of the all-time grades.
Yeah, one of the all-time grades.
You know, Willie, anytime anybody brings up these folks,
90年代中期的即兴表演场景，真的很有趣。然后我会在Second City做服务生，我会看到Tina刚开始的时候，像Scott Adtson，Brian Stack，很多，你知道，Cohen的家伙，Jerry Miner，简直是惊人的杀手。Stack是史上最伟大的人之一。是的，史上最伟大的人之一。你知道，Willie，每当有人提起这些人，
you know them all, but did you ever do any time at one of the time?
of these improv groups?
No, I was too dumb.
Like, I was living in New York
and there wasn't that same thing
and I wish I had.
I didn't know about it.
You were going to a lot of them
你都认识他们，但你有没有在这些即兴表演团体里待过？不，我太笨了。就像，我住在纽约，没有那种东西，我希望我有。我不知道。你去了很多
and you were hanging out with them a lot.
This is even before Amy, right?
It's probably how you met Amy.
So when Amy first came to New York
with Matt and Matt and Ian as UCB,
they did the bucket of truth
and they did the West Bank downstairs
and one of my then agents,
而且你和他们混在一起很多。这甚至在Amy之前，对吧？这可能是你认识Amy的方式。所以当Amy第一次和Matt、Matt和Ian作为UCB来到纽约时，他们做了Bucket of Truth，他们在West Bank楼下表演，我当时的一个经纪人，
a man by the name of Peter Principato.
My current manager.
His current, Mike's current manager.
said to me, you've got to go and see this group that I represent,
these were doing this thing called Bucket of Truth.
So I went there, and that was 1996.
They just moved in January of 96.
I know all this.
一个叫Peter Principato的人。我现在的经理。Mike现在的经理。对我说，你必须去看看我代理的这个团体，他们正在做一件叫Bucket of Truth的事情。所以我去了，那是1996年。他们刚在96年1月搬来。我知道这一切。
They moved in January of 96 to New York.
I went and saw a bucket of truth with my buddy, our buddy Duff,
and my then-girlfriend, Missy Yeager.
I know Duff.
Yeah.
But anyway, I remember seeing those guys and be like, holy shit.
And this is what was going on in Chicago,
what all you guys were doing.
他们在96年1月搬到了纽约。我和我的哥们，我们的哥们Duff，还有我当时的女友Missy Yeager一起去看了Bucket of Truth。我认识Duff。是的。但无论如何，我记得看到那些家伙，心想，天哪。这就是芝加哥正在发生的事情，你们所有人正在做的事情。
Yeah.
And it wasn't in New York.
And they brought it to New York,
UCB, Amy and those guys.
But it didn't exist. I wish I had done it.
I was too dumb. And by then I got to know everybody
obviously because I was around all those.
Will, do you remember in like 2000,
是的。而且不在纽约。他们把它带到了纽约，UCB，Amy和那些家伙。但它不存在。我希望我做过。我太笨了。到那时我显然认识了每个人，因为我一直在那些人周围。Will，你记得在2000年左右吗，
maybe two or three together?
We did a reading of Jerry Lewis's
the day the clown cried. Fuck, yes.
You meet Cross.
John Glazer. John Glazer.
God, who else? Rob Hubel.
And for my sister, the day
the clown cried is about a clown that visits
也许两三个人在一起？我们做了一次Jerry Lewis的《小丑哭泣的那一天》的朗读。该死，是的。你遇见Cross。John Glazer。John Glazer。天哪，还有谁？Rob Hubel。对我姐姐来说，《小丑哭泣的那一天》是关于一个小丑拜访
the kids in the Holocaust.
Yes. And it's a movie that famously
was never released, right?
Yeah, yeah.
It was Jerry Lewis plays a Jewish clown
who entertains the children
as they're about to be murdered,
and for some reason, they never released it.
大屠杀中的孩子们。是的。这是一部著名的从未发行的电影，对吧？是的，是的。Jerry Lewis扮演一个犹太小丑，在孩子们即将被谋杀时娱乐他们，出于某种原因，他们从未发行它。
Yeah.
But was it, was it Jerry Lewis that killed it?
Did he, like, try to bury it?
Or was it, was it the financier?
No, he.
I think Jerry Lewis himself was like, no, no, no,
we can't show anyone this.
But the rumor is,
是的。但那是Jerry Lewis杀死了它吗？他，就像，试图埋葬它？还是，还是金融家？不，他。我想Jerry Lewis本人就像，不，不，不，我们不能给任何人看这个。但传言是，
the rumor is that Harry Shearer has a copy of it.
Like, isn't that really?
There are some clips on YouTube.
There's some clips on YouTube,
but you can type it in and see, like,
like, little small.
small moments and stuff.
Oh, really?
传言是Harry Shearer有一份拷贝。就像，那不是真的吗？YouTube上有一些片段。YouTube上有一些片段，但你可以输入它并看到，就像，像，小小的。小小的时刻之类的。哦，真的吗？
The whole thing isn't out there yet.
Whoa.
Yeah, we did that.
I forgot about it.
And there was a crate,
that was so much fun and everybody,
and not just everybody on the stage,
but everybody in the audience,
整个东西还没出来。哇。是的，我们做了那个。我忘了。那是一个板条箱，那太有趣了，每个人，不仅是舞台上的每个人，还有观众席上的每个人，
it was so much people of that era.
It was the first time I felt cool on stage
doing comedy.
Like, there was cool people around,
and I felt very cool for the first time.
Now, let's go back.
I heard you say something like,
college did not work out for you,
那是那个时代的人。那是我第一次在舞台上做喜剧感到酷。就像，周围有很酷的人，我第一次感到非常酷。现在，让我们回去。我听到你说类似大学没为你成功，
or something like that.
It was a bit of a breeze over there.
Let's double back.
to that and let's talk about um so from day one he loves pain points he loves hitting pain points
so you show up you got your suitcases and go from there i i want i went into boston university
hoping i would be a politician and then really really yeah yeah are you still interested in politics
um i'm disgusted by it right yeah but i i i do yes that's a yes i'm perverted i know a lot about it
we don't have to talk about politics but i'm just just curious okay so you're studying poli
或者类似的话。那儿有点轻描淡写。让我们回过头来。谈谈嗯，从第一天起，他就喜欢痛点，他喜欢触碰痛点。所以你出现了，你带着行李箱，从那儿开始。我，我去了波士顿大学，希望我能成为一名政治家，然后真的真的，是的，是的，你还对政治感兴趣吗？嗯，我对此感到厌恶，对吧，是的，但我，我确实，是的，那是肯定的，我是个变态，我知道很多关于它的事，我们不必谈论政治，但我只是，只是好奇，好的，所以你在学习政治
at Boston U, so you're not a dummy.
I was going to, and then right away,
I went crazy where I was like, oh my God,
if I'd never smoked pot or done mushrooms before,
that started happening quite a bit.
Oh, you started to have some bad trips.
And then I was just, the freedom of not having to do anything
took me over, and I kind of went crazy for a couple weeks
在波士顿大学，所以你不是个笨蛋。我本来要，然后立刻，我疯了，我当时想，天哪，如果我以前从没抽过大麻或吃过蘑菇，那开始发生得相当多。哦，你开始有几次糟糕的旅行了。然后我只是，不用做任何事的自由占据了我，我疯了几个星期
and watched movies over and over again.
And, like, I watched 2001, like seven or eight times.
Same Zee's?
Yeah, and I kind of halfway.
through the semester, I was like, this isn't, I'm not.
I need more structure.
Yeah, and I just wasn't enjoying that.
And so I, I, I couldn't handle the freedom.
一遍又一遍地看电影。而且，就像，我看了《2001》七八次。同样的Zee？是的，我有点半途而废。学期过了一半，我当时想，这不是，我不是。我需要更多的结构。是的，我只是不喜欢那样。所以我，我，我无法处理自由。
I couldn't handle the freedom.
I felt bad for my parents, so I told them everything was status quo and it was going great.
And when I came home and finished the year, my dad is a reward, took me to Las Vegas and
LA on a vacation because I finished my first year of college.
And literally on the way to the airport, my mom called.
and was like, I just got a letter from BU.
They're kicking him out.
And that was problematic.
我无法处理自由。我为我的父母感到难过，所以我告诉他们一切照旧，一切都很顺利。当我回家完成这一年时，我爸爸作为奖励，带我去了拉斯维加斯和洛杉矶度假，因为我完成了大学第一年。就在去机场的路上，我妈妈打电话。就像，我刚收到BU的信。他们要开除他。那很有问题。
Trips still on, right?
The trip was literally, we were done and flying back home.
And, like, we sat on a Southwest flight.
And my dad for, like, three hours was like,
how could you do this to us?
And I was like, I'm really sorry.
But now they're very happy and everything's good.
Of course, they should be.
旅行还在继续，对吧？旅行实际上是，我们结束了，正飞回家。而且，就像，我们坐在西南航空的航班上。我爸爸有三个小时就像，你怎么能这样对我们？我当时就像，我真的很抱歉。但现在他们非常高兴，一切都很好。当然，他们应该这样。
So then you stay in Chicago
and you just start some odd jobs
and going to the comedy clubs
and at what point did you go all in on having a conversation with your parents
about I'm going to pursue entertainment?
They knew that I was really enjoying improv and everything,
and at that time, your kind of goal is to be on the second city main stage
and then eventually SNL.
所以你留在芝加哥，你只是开始做一些零工，去喜剧俱乐部，你在什么时候决定全力以赴与你的父母谈论我要追求娱乐？他们知道我真的很喜欢即兴表演和所有东西，在那个时候，你的目标是成为Second City主舞台，然后最终是SNL。
That's the ultimate trajectory.
And after a few years, I auditioned for this theater group in Amsterdam
called Boom Chicago.
You know, a lot of our friends have gone through.
And that is where your job is acting.
You don't have to have another day job,
you just have to do shows at night.
And I got hired by them and my parents.
那是最终的轨迹。几年后，我为阿姆斯特丹的一个叫Boom Chicago的剧团试镜。你知道，我们的很多朋友都经历过。那是你的工作是表演的地方。你不必有另一份日常工作，你只需要晚上做演出。我被他们雇用了，我的父母。
I told them, hey, this is it, I'm leaving.
I'm doing this now.
I'm an actor.
And they have been, they're like the most supportive parent.
My dad became an actor.
Like, you know what I mean?
It's like, it's crazy.
They are very, very probably.
我告诉他们，嘿，就是这样，我要走了。我现在在做这个。我是个演员。他们一直，他们是最支持的父母。我爸爸成了演员。就像，你知道我的意思吗？这太疯狂了。他们非常，非常可能。
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm now remembering the reason I brought up in him to him.
I think the first time we met was like 2001 or maybe two.
And you and Josh Meyer, Seth's brother,
came back from Amsterdam and came to Amy,
our old old apartment.
Yes.
Do you remember that?
等等，等等，等等。我现在记起我提起他的原因了。我想我们第一次见面是在2001年或也许是2002年。你和Josh Meyer，Seth的兄弟，从阿姆斯特丹回来，来到Amy，我们旧旧的公寓。是的。你记得吗？
Yeah,
and Farrell was there.
Yes.
It was right after she got hired by SNL.
Yeah, it was that first season
because Seth got hired at the same time.
是的，Farrell当时在那儿。是的。是的。就在她被SNL雇用之后。是的。是的，那是第一季，因为Seth在同一时间被雇用。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's crazy.
I've known you a long time, Will.
That was 25 years ago, dude.
Yeah, it's nuts.
Wow.
Okay.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。威尔，我认识你很久了。那已经是25年前的事了，伙计。是啊，太不可思议了。哇。好吧。
It's crazy.
All right.
So you, so you, then they go, okay, great.
You're going to do it.
You're going to be, and they're supportive.
Very supportive.
and...
Do you have brothers and sisters?
太疯狂了。好吧。所以你，所以你，然后他们说，好的，太棒了。你要去做了。你要成为，而且他们很支持。非常支持。而且……你有兄弟姐妹吗？
Younger brother,
and then he decided he wanted to be an actor too
and I was like, dude, don't do it.
But he now, he works,
he was on Superstore for years
and creates shows and stuff.
So we're like a...
We're a showbiz family now.
有个弟弟，后来他也决定要当演员，我就说，伙计，别干这行。但他现在，他有工作，他在《超市特工》里演了好几年，还创作节目之类的。所以我们就像一个……我们现在是演艺世家了。
We're like the Arquettes.
So mom is the only one without a sad card at this point.
Mom is the only one
we're trying to taft Hartley her
and get her to like be on something.
But she'll be tough,
but we'll get her there.
We'll get you there, Peggy.
我们就像阿奎特一家。所以现在只有我妈没有演员工会卡了。我妈是唯一一个我们正试图帮她加入工会，让她去演点什么的人。但这会很难，但我们会搞定的。我们会让你做到的，佩吉。
But how did you get dialed into that whole crew of all the comedy?
How did you get in?
What was your first foray into that world?
Well, moved to L.A. with Seth Myers and Josh Myers
and my buddy Dave.
And for like a year and a half, it was like a bus boy
and just trying to break into stuff.
But it was Mad TV was my first gig.
但是你是怎么进入那个喜剧圈子的？你是怎么进去的？你第一次涉足那个世界是什么时候？嗯，我和塞斯·迈耶斯、乔什·迈耶斯还有我的好友戴夫搬到了洛杉矶。大概有一年半的时间，我就是个打杂的，一直在努力寻找机会。但《疯狂电视》是我第一份工作。
I got hired with Josh Myers.
And I did five years on Mad TV.
Wow.
I watched a lot of those.
I used to love you and Josh on that.
Truly.
It was, you know, it was one of those shows.
I loved doing it until I didn't.
我和乔什·迈耶斯一起被录用了。我在《疯狂电视》干了五年。哇。我看了很多集。我以前超喜欢你和乔什在里面的表现。真的。你知道，那确实是那种节目。我一直很喜欢做那个，直到后来不喜欢了。
It was tough at the time because SNL,
I think that's the best SNL cast ever,
that like 2002 to 2008-ish, you know what I mean?
That was just like Polar and Will and Whig and Fred,
and it was just wild.
And we would always get compared to them.
And it was just tough because sometimes you wanted mad to be a little bit better.
You wanted it to kind of not have kind of like,
当时很难，因为《周六夜现场》，我觉得那是史上最棒的《周六夜现场》阵容，大概是2002年到2008年左右，你懂我的意思吗？那是波勒、威尔、威格和弗雷德的时代，简直太疯狂了。我们总是被拿来和他们比较。这很难，因为有时候你希望《疯狂电视》能更好一点。你希望它不要有那种……
guests and stuff, but it was a great job.
Didn't you guys have like a half hour jump start before?
Did you guys come on at 11?
We did.
We came on at 11, so we had a little bit of a head start.
And it was, I will say, it was very fun.
My first TV show, I'm still friends with those guys.
Like Jordan was on there.
嘉宾之类的，但那是一份很棒的工作。你们之前不是有半小时的领先优势吗？你们是11点开始吗？是的。我们11点开始，所以我们有一点先发优势。而且，我得说，那真的很有趣。那是我的第一个电视节目，我至今还和那些家伙是朋友。比如乔丹就在那儿。
Jordan Peel is like one of my best friends.
And we had a, it was very fun.
But towards the end, I was getting restless.
And I was like, I need to be on a different show.
I want to be on a sitcom.
And then I left Mad TV and they literally did not work for like three and a
That is the curse of a series, right?
He starts feeling like all the things you're not being able to do
乔丹·皮尔是我最好的朋友之一。我们当时，真的很有趣。但到了后期，我开始感到不安。我就想，我需要去别的节目。我想演情景喜剧。然后我离开了《疯狂电视》，他们真的有三年半没工作……这就是系列剧的诅咒，对吧？你开始觉得所有你做不到的事情……
and then you leave and it's like, oh, there's a lot of crickets out there.
Who is the guy who famously did that?
What was the guy he was on that show?
He was on NYPD Blue.
David Caruso, baby.
David Crusoe, yeah.
Well, in fairness to him, there's a long list of folks that think that's pretty
having a very long career and he had a big show after that too.
然后你离开了，就像，哦，外面一片寂静。那个著名地做了这件事的人是谁？他在那个节目里演谁来着？他在《纽约重案组》里。大卫·卡鲁索，宝贝。大卫·卡鲁索，没错。好吧，平心而论，有一长串的人认为那是相当……他有着非常漫长的职业生涯，在那之后他也有一部大剧。
He was awesome.
Yeah, he did do CSI.
But then you did, and correct me if I'm wrong.
So then after that, you do that and you do a couple things here and there,
but it was then the Mindy project, right?
Yeah.
That was the next big.
Well, basically, I did get, Danny McBride did cast me on Eastbound and Down at a time.
他太棒了。是的，他确实演了《犯罪现场调查》。但后来你演了，如果我说错了请纠正我。所以在那之后，你演了那个，零零散散演了几样东西，但后来是《明迪烦事多》，对吧？是的。那是下一个大项目。嗯，基本上，丹尼·麦克布莱德确实让我在《体育老师笑传》里演了一个角色。
Oh, okay, got it.
I just was not working, and that was like a big deal for me.
Yes, that show.
That show, that group.
Oh, they're the best.
They are the best.
I just saw him.
I love them.
哦，好的，明白了。我当时就是没工作，那对我来说是一件大事。是的，那个节目。那个节目，那个团队。哦，他们是最棒的。他们真的是最棒的。我刚见过他。我爱他们。
They're so cool.
They're so original.
And that was the first time I went.
onto a show that I was a die-hard fan of.
So was it a little nerve-wracking at the beginning then?
Was it what you thought it was going to be just as a viewer?
I was nervous enough just like, I hope I'm as funny as these guys,
but I also had to be a baseball player.
他们太酷了。他们太有原创性了。那是我第一次加入一个我本身就是死忠粉的节目。所以刚开始的时候有点紧张吗？作为观众，它和你想象的一样吗？我当时紧张得只是想，希望我能像这些家伙一样搞笑，但我还得演一个棒球运动员。
I had to be like the best pitcher in the world.
And you don't have a lot of baseball talent?
I have a little bit of baseball.
I'm like a solid five, but that was a little bit of pressure.
You don't look like you're throwing with your left hand, you know.
don't look like, no, no, no.
I've seen, like, bad, like, Robert Redford's son in The Natural.
Like, when he throws it, it looks so bad.
我得演世界上最好的投手。你没什么棒球天赋吗？我有一点棒球底子。我大概有五分水平，但这确实有点压力。你看上去不像是在用左手投球，你知道的。不像，不，不，不。我见过，比如，很烂的，罗伯特·雷德福的儿子在《天生好手》里。他投球的时候，看起来太烂了。
It looks so bad.
I'm not that bad, but I'm not bad.
I just saw a clip of the natural the other day,
and Robert Reffield, you know, when he strikes out that guy,
when the train pulls over.
Joe Don Baker, yeah.
And Redford had a pretty good release.
He had skills.
看起来太烂了。我没那么烂，但我也不坏。我前几天刚看了《天生好手》的片段，罗伯特·雷德福，你知道，当他三振那个家伙时，火车停下来的时候。乔·唐·贝克，没错。雷德福的出手姿势相当不错。他有技巧。
He was a good athlete.
You could tell he was a good athlete.
Who's not?
It's pretty clear when you watch him.
But, yeah, there was pressure,
but it was like so much fun and I love those guys.
And from there,
would you consider yourself the Redford of Eastbound and Down?
他是个优秀的运动员。看得出来他是个优秀的运动员。谁不是呢？当你看着他的时候就很清楚了。但是，是的，确实有压力，但那真的太有趣了，我爱那些家伙。从那以后，你会认为自己是《体育老师笑传》里的雷德福吗？
Oh, for sure.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, yeah.
The Redford and the Newman, quite frankly.
And the Newman, of course, yeah.
Whatever I mean.
Both of them.
So you do Eastbound and Down with those guys,
哦，当然。是的，当然。是啊，是啊。坦白说，是雷德福和纽曼。当然还有纽曼，没错。不管我指的是什么。他们两个都是。所以你和那些家伙一起演了《体育老师笑传》，
but then the Mindy project you do it for a few years.
You guys did like a lot of episodes.
It did six seasons, man.
Yeah, six seasons.
Wow.
It's crazy now.
We complain about 10 episode shows,
and it's like, we used to do 22 episodes.
但后来你演了几年《明迪烦事多》。你们拍了很多集。拍了六季，伙计。是的，六季。哇。现在想想太疯狂了。我们抱怨10集的剧，而以前我们拍22集。
It was nuts.
A year every year, yeah.
Yeah.
It was nuts.
And through that,
process you and Mindy get closer because you've ended up collaborating since then and you guys
have written together you guys created Running Point I think I mentioned that in the open with Dave
Dasen my writing partner and best friend who is the true showrunner but the three of us we love her
太疯狂了。一年又一年，是的。是的。太疯狂了。在这个过程中，你和明迪变得更亲近了，因为从那以后你们最终合作了，你们一起写过剧本，你们创作了《Running Point》，我想我在开场时提到了，和我的写作搭档兼最好的朋友戴夫·达森一起，他是真正的剧集主管，但我们三个，我们爱她。
look we're not here to talk about Dave okay can we just talk about him for just a second no I mean we're
here to talk about you okay and Chuck Arnett but we're not here to talk about Dave okay I don't know
I don't know if Jason remembers this but in like 2019 I sat next to Jason at the Emmys my wife and I
He does not remember.
He does not.
Right at the time.
听着，我们不是来谈论戴夫的，好吗？我们能只谈他一秒钟吗？不，我的意思是，我们是来谈论你的，好吗？还有查克·阿内特，但我们不是来谈论戴夫的，好吗？我不知道，我不知道杰森是否记得这个，大概在2019年，我在艾美奖上坐在杰森旁边，我和我妻子。他不记得了。他真的不记得。就在当时。就在当时。就在当时。
He's starting to come back.
Some horrible, like, abortion ban hit Georgia.
Oh, Atlanta.
Yeah.
And we were talking about it.
And I was like, yeah, I actually do a lot of work with the ACLU.
Uh-oh.
他开始想起来了。一些可怕的，比如，堕胎禁令在佐治亚州生效了。哦，亚特兰大。是的。是的。我们当时在谈论这个。我就说，是的，我实际上和美国公民自由联盟做了很多工作。噢噢。
And Jason goes, have they filed a lawsuit yet?
And I go, you know what?
I don't know.
He goes, well, you really have your talking points in order,
and they're lucky to have you as an ambassador.
Wow.
Like, lucky.
And locked and loaded and ready to go.
然后杰森说，他们提起诉讼了吗？我说，你知道吗？我不知道。他说，好吧，你的谈话要点整理得真好，他们有你这样的大使真是幸运。哇。就像，幸运。而且准备充分，随时待命。
I didn't know him that well.
I was a lot.
I figured we'd skip a few dates
and I'd just get right to hurtful.
Sorry, I must have been nervous that night.
No, it was very funny.
You were too busy winning multiple Emmys at that day.
No, I didn't.
我当时对他没那么熟。我当时太……我以为我们会跳过几个日期，直接进入伤人的话题。抱歉，那天晚上我一定很紧张。不，那非常有趣。你那天忙着赢好几个艾美奖呢。不，我没有。
Didn't Ozark win some Emmy?
Ozark won a lot.
That was, was that when I won for directing?
Maybe.
Yeah, I think I've had a few SAG Awards.
He acts like it.
Yeah, let's go back.
Is that what I won for directing?
《黑钱胜地》没赢艾美奖吗？《黑钱胜地》赢了很多。那是，那是我因为导演获奖的时候吗？也许吧。是的，我想我拿过几个演员工会奖。他表现得好像是那样。是的，让我们回到正题。那是我因为导演获奖的时候吗？
I didn't remember.
Oh, sorry, that's my cue.
Oh, you won for directing?
No, no, no, no, no.
Guys, just trim this part.
Or just tag it and we'll just...
Why are you saying trim it, but you're shaking your head, no.
Wait, is my camera on?
我不记得了。哦，抱歉，那是我的提示。哦，你因为导演获奖了？不，不，不，不，不。伙计们，把这段剪掉。或者只是标记一下，我们……你为什么说剪掉它，但你却在摇头说不。等等，我的摄像头开着吗？
So, but I wanted to get, like, so you,
what's awesome is, is that you, that you do all these shows and stuff,
and now you're kind of, you've expanded,
and you're writing and creating shows with Dave, your writing partner.
And you guys are, and you've got a kind of a very robust career going in a lot of different ways.
And you're doing, you're creating Running Point, you're on that.
You're doing the studio with Seth and Evan, those guys, which is awesome.
I mean, you're so good on that show.
所以，但我想要得到的是，所以你，最棒的是，你演了所有这些节目之类的，现在你有点，你已经扩展了，你正在和你的写作搭档戴夫一起写作和创作节目。你们正在，而且你在很多不同的方面都有非常稳健的职业生涯。你正在做，你正在创作《Running Point》，你在演那个。你正在和塞斯和埃文一起做《The Studio》，那些家伙，这太棒了。我的意思是，你在那个节目里表现得太好了。
Real busty right now.
Yeah, it's such a good show.
You are so good on that show, dude.
It's amazing.
That's really nice to you guys.
It's really fun.
We're like, we got three weeks left of shooting season two, and it's, it's, it's, it's
been long but really fun
现在真的很忙。是的，那是个非常好的节目。你在那个节目里表现得太好了，伙计。太神奇了。这对你们来说真是太好了。真的很有趣。我们就像，我们还剩三周就要拍完第二季了，而且，它，它，它，它一直很漫长但真的很有趣。
and really
yeah I love that
I went to Venice for two weeks
we shot for two weeks in Venice
I saw that yeah
with Madonna
in the show
oh that's right
而且真的，是的，我喜欢那个，我去了威尼斯两周，我们在威尼斯拍了两周。我看到了，是的，和麦当娜一起在节目里。哦，对了。
yeah yeah
you know
wait to drop that
fuck it
I'm like the Fred Norris of this show
yeah
hey Fred
pump it
是啊，是啊，你知道，等着放出那个，去他的，我就像这个节目的弗雷德·诺里斯，是啊，嘿弗雷德，泵起来。
okay
give a reel up in the field
eyes
I was so ready
I'm just doing old
old
I would love to
what are you saying
好的，在现场把卷轴拿起来，我准备好了，我只是在做旧的，旧的，我很乐意，你在说什么。
I would love to
Shut up
Sit out
You idiot
Don't touch it you idiot
I told you not to be stupid
You moron
我很乐意，我很乐意，闭嘴，坐下，你这个白痴，别碰它，你这个白痴，我告诉过你不要犯蠢，你这个笨蛋。
Wait so I
When you do all
Sorry Sean
What were you asking
Yeah Sean
What were you saying
Sean do you want to say something
Go for Sean
等等，所以我，当你做所有，抱歉肖恩，你在问什么，是的肖恩，你在说什么，肖恩，你想说什么，去吧肖恩。
Wait is that on your third button
On your phone
So it's always there and ready
It's ready to go
It's so fun
I'm having a lot of fun right now
I'm so jacked up on coffee.
Ike's here.
等等，那是在你的第三个按钮上吗？在你的手机上？所以它总是在那里准备好了？它准备好了。太有趣了。我现在玩得很开心。我喝咖啡喝得太兴奋了。艾克在这儿。
Ike likes to fuck around.
I'm in a Yerba Mante sweat.
Yeah.
Oh, man, guys.
Okay, so Sean, you had something?
So I had a question about how do you balance family?
Oh, for fuck, sake.
You know, for real?
艾克喜欢胡闹。我穿着一件马黛茶汗衫。是啊。哦，天哪，伙计们。好吧，所以肖恩，你有什么事吗？所以我有一个关于你如何平衡家庭的问题。哦，去他妈的。你知道，认真的吗？
Right.
What's your great?
Working life.
Well, because like you said, you're like in Venice and you're doing this.
You're doing like 18 shows at the same time, but you have how many kids you have?
I have three daughters.
Come on.
Wow.
对。你的伟大之处。工作生活。嗯，因为就像你说的，你就像在威尼斯，你在做这个。你同时在做18个节目，但你有几个孩子？我有三个女儿。得了吧。哇。
Curled down.
And I'm not home as much as I like,
but my wife's boyfriend is a great guy.
Oh, I'm sorry.
And he, it was kind of rocky at first
between me and him for obvious reasons.
But now it's got modern.
He's, like, really good, and he's really good with my kids.
冷静点。我回家的时间没有我希望的那么多，但我妻子的男朋友是个很棒的家伙。哦，我很抱歉。而且他，我和他起初因为显而易见的原因有点僵。但现在变得很现代了。他，就像，真的很好，而且他对我的孩子们真的很好。
Yeah.
You're not crying?
So, yeah, we're just kind of letting that ride.
Is he still doing the M.MA stuff?
Is he still into that?
Yeah.
Well, you guys know Andrew Tate.
You've heard of Andrew.
是啊。你没哭吧？所以，是的，我们只是顺其自然。他还在做综合格斗那些事吗？他还在沉迷那个吗？是的。好吧，你们认识安德鲁·泰特。你们听说过安德鲁。
Yeah.
He's actually not as bad.
And how do your daughters get along with his four pit bulls?
Is it like pretty good?
是啊。是啊。是啊。是啊。他其实没那么坏。是啊。那你的女儿们和他的四只比特犬相处得怎么样？还挺好的吗？
Now, yes.
Now they have the mouth guards.
Sure.
Yeah, the muzzles.
They can't bite now.
But it was a little touch and go from it.
Oh, my God.
And we will be right back.
现在，是的。现在她们有护齿了。当然。是的，嘴套。它们现在咬不了人了。但起初有点悬。哦，天哪。我们马上回来。
And back to the show.
How old are the little angels?
The little angel.
Hello, little angels.
They're listening.
They are eight, ten, and soon to be 13.
Wow.
Right in the zone.
回到节目。小天使们多大了？小天使。你好，小天使们。她们在听。她们分别是八岁、十岁，快13岁了。哇。正好在那个阶段。
So nice.
You know, it's fun.
I watch an interview with Bob Odenkirk and Mike Barbiglia asked him.
He's like, who are you jealous of?
And he meant like professionally.
Yeah.
And Bob goes, oh, anyone that still has little kids at home.
And I was like, oh, it's so sweet.
真好。你知道，这很有趣。我看了一个鲍勃·奥登科克的采访，迈克·巴比利亚问他。他说，你嫉妒谁？他指的是职业上。是的。然后鲍勃说，哦，任何家里还有小孩的人。我就想，哦，太甜了。
I got a 14-year-old still in the house and I'd just like to keep her in a box.
I'd stop it right there.
I know.
And does.
And you do.
I do.
I put a punch little holes in the top of it.
我家里还有一个14岁的孩子，我真想把她关在盒子里。我就在那儿停下。我知道。而且确实。你做到了。我做到了。我做到了。我在上面戳了几个小孔。
Yeah.
It is true. It is true. It is the best part is keeping them young. It's so good.
Don't. I got a little six. My guy's about to turn six.
Yeah.
And I saw. What are you going to do for him? Hold on, Ike.
We're doing a, we're doing a party at a place called.
Don't you just say the name of the place.
是啊。这是真的。这是真的。最棒的部分就是让她们保持年轻。太好了。别。我有一个六岁的小家伙。我的孩子快六岁了。是啊。是啊。我看到了。你打算为他做什么？等等，艾克。我们正在做一个，我们正在一个叫……的地方办派对。你别直接说那个地方的名字。
I like it because it's got ninja in the name, but it doesn't matter.
Are you looking for a break? No, you're looking for a break on the place.
I want a mind. By the way, they're crushing me on the price for this thing for a couple kids.
You want it on the weekend, right?
You do it during the week, you get a real deal.
Fucking Brooklyn.
Jesus Christ.
It's going to be fun.
我喜欢它，因为名字里有忍者，但这不重要。你在找折扣吗？不，你在找那个地方的折扣。我想要一个。顺便说一句，他们在这个东西的价格上宰了我一顿，为了几个孩子。你想要在周末，对吧？你在工作日做，你会得到一个真正的优惠。该死的布鲁克林。天哪。这会很有趣。
It's going to be a lot of fun.
Anyway, so Ike, so Ike, so you're the life, work-life balance that John Lernernerner is so desperate to know about, it's fine.
You figure it out, you're working, everybody knows, dad's on the...
Yes.
And by the way, we talk about it all the time, we go away.
But everybody has busy...
My dad wasn't an actor, but he was busy a lot.
He was off working, and he had to be busy a lot.
这会很有趣。总之，所以艾克，所以艾克，所以你是约翰·勒纳纳纳纳如此渴望知道的工作生活平衡，没关系。你搞定了，你在工作，每个人都知道，爸爸在……是的。顺便说一句，我们一直在谈论它，我们离开。但每个人都很忙……我爸爸不是演员，但他经常很忙。他经常出去工作，他必须经常很忙。
He was off working, and he acts, he was like, I got to provide for the family, so he's off doing his show.
He's driving down to...
He's driving down to Moulson, and he's checking the taps,
and then he's coming home, you know?
Still fresh, boys.
He's not flying off somewhere.
He was on the road a lot, right, Sean?
Yeah.
他出去工作，他表现得，他就像，我得养家糊口，所以他出去做他的节目。他开车去……他开车去莫尔森，检查水龙头，然后回家，你知道吗？依然新鲜，伙计们。他没有飞到什么地方去。他在路上待了很久，对吧，肖恩？是啊。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's a Knickerbocker?
Oh, well, this is an old phrase from New York City.
It means like a metropolitan fellow, maybe.
Where I believe it is, yes, let's go with that.
I believe it is a, no, I don't think it's necessarily a dandy.
I'm not to that since you said it.
But Will, are you, are you searching it?
是啊，是啊，是啊。什么是尼克博克？哦，好吧，这是一个来自纽约市的古老短语。它意味着像一个大都市的家伙，也许。我相信它是，是的，我们就这么说吧。我相信它是一个，不，我不认为它一定是花花公子。既然你说了，我就不提了。但是威尔，你在，你在搜索它吗？
I'm going to search it up here.
No, I'm not.
Let's go to our next question.
Hey, Siri, what's a Knickerbocker?
Oh, descendant of the original Dutch settlers.
Or knickers in the United States are a form of baggy knee britches.
No, is the person descended from the original Dutch settlers of New York
or more broadly a native or resident of New York City?
我在这里搜索一下。不，我没有。让我们进入下一个问题。嘿，Siri，什么是尼克博克？哦，最初的荷兰定居者的后裔。或者在美国，灯笼裤是一种宽松的膝盖短裤。不，是那个人的后裔来自纽约最初的荷兰定居者，或者更广泛地说是纽约市的本地人或居民吗？
Do you guys like trivia?
Are you guys, are there any of you trivia heads?
No.
I wouldn't do.
I'm a little bit.
I watch Jeopardy.
So I was going to mention this,
Ike's got a trivia podcast that he's doing now
你们喜欢冷知识吗？你们是，你们中有任何冷知识达人吗？不。我不会。我有一点。我看《危险边缘》。所以我正要提这个，艾克现在有一个冷知识播客。
that we're always going to plug after.
Oh, for real?
Yeah, yeah. Funny, you ask.
So Will was going to do it and he texted me.
And he's like, hey, man, I can't do it.
And I thought it was going to be like,
I didn't sound like that one text, by the way.
But, go ahead.
我们之后总是会宣传的。哦，真的吗？是啊，是啊。问得好。所以威尔本来要做的，他给我发了短信。他说，嘿，伙计，我做不了。我以为会是，顺便说一句，听起来不像那条短信。但是，继续。
That's how I read your text.
And I thought it was going to be like, you know,
a work thing came up or a kid thing.
And he's like, I can't.
Bateman really wants to go golfing.
Oh.
You, how dare you will?
I sold you out.
我是那样读你的短信的。我以为会是，你知道，工作上的事或者孩子的事。他说，我做不了。贝特曼真的很想去打高尔夫。哦。你，你怎么敢，威尔？我把你卖了。
You go, because Jason, well, it was here, I did tell you this like.
Was that, that thing a couple weeks ago?
It's the last time he played, yeah, it was the last time he was playing before he was leaving town.
Before he's moving for New York.
So Bavon says, I'll do it.
And so Bavon texted me, well, why don't you just reschedule?
I don't sound like that on text.
我把你卖了。你说，因为杰森，好吧，它就在这儿，我确实告诉过你这个。是那个，几周前的事吗？那是他最后一次打球，是的，那是他离开城里前最后一次打球。在他搬去纽约之前。所以巴冯说，我会做的。所以巴冯给我发了短信，好吧，你为什么不重新安排时间？我发短信时听起来不像那样。
Why do you just reschedule with I can do it on a later day and join me on the golf course tomorrow?
I don't want to sound like Paul Lynn.
That's who it is.
That's who you sound like.
I've been trying to place it.
Now, but did he offer...
And so I had to be honest.
I wanted to be honest with...
你为什么不和艾克重新安排时间，改天做，明天在高尔夫球场加入我？我不想听起来像保罗·林恩。那就是他。你听起来就像他。我一直在试图定位它。现在，但他提供了……所以我必须诚实。我想诚实地对待……
And I truly appreciate that.
Because if he would have been like,
I have a work thing, and then I went golfing and saw him there, I'd be crushed.
Did you offer him a rescheduling date?
Well, he did.
He did. I did.
He's out of town, and I'm waiting for him to get back and I'm going to do it.
We're actually going to do it right after we finish this pot.
我真的很感激这一点。因为如果他当时说，我有工作上的事，然后我去打高尔夫球看到他在那儿，我会崩溃的。你给他提供了一个重新安排的日期吗？好吧，他确实提供了。他确实提供了。我提供了。他出城了，我正在等他回来，我要去做。我们实际上要在录完这个播客后马上做。
Yeah, we're going to do it.
Wait, you got some questions, I do have some questions for you guys.
I started a trivia podcast because I love
trivia, right?
I'm obsessed with trivia.
I've gone on...
Have you been on Jeopardy?
I won Celebrity, Jeopardy, Mr. Bateman.
是啊，我们要去做。等等，你有一些问题，我确实有一些问题要问你们。我开始了一个冷知识播客，因为我喜欢冷知识，对吧？我沉迷于冷知识。我去过……你上过《危险边缘》吗？我赢了名人版《危险边缘》，贝特曼先生。
Wait, whoa, wow.
I didn't know that.
I won celebrity Jeopardy.
He's one who wants to be a millionaire.
Whoa.
I want celebrity who wants to be a millionaire.
What's the game in the bars?
In the bars?
等等，哇，哇。我不知道。我赢了名人版《危险边缘》。他是那个想成为百万富翁的人。哇。我赢了名人版《谁想成为百万富翁》。酒吧里的游戏是什么？在酒吧里？
Oh, pub trivia?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I've done that before.
That's very fun.
But I want to do a podcast where I interview friends of mine
who are, like, funny or cool,
and then ask them trivia questions
哦，酒吧冷知识？是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。是啊，我以前做过。那非常有趣。那非常有趣。但我想要做一个播客，采访我的朋友，他们，比如，搞笑或很酷，然后问他们冷知识问题。
about subjects that they kind of...
I'd love to read for it.
We are out to your people, I'm sure.
Do you guys want a couple of questions?
I wrote some questions for you.
Obviously, obviously.
Okay, let's go, let's go.
You can just call out the answer if you know it, okay?
关于他们有点……我很乐意读一下。我肯定我们已经联系到你的人了。你们想要几个问题吗？我为你们写了一些问题。显然，显然。好吧，我们开始吧，我们开始吧。如果你知道答案，可以直接喊出来，好吗？
There's no buzzer?
No, just say your name for the buzzer.
Okay.
Okay, blah, blah, when the Battle of the Hastings...
Jason.
What do you got?
Sorry.
1940.
没有蜂鸣器吗？不，只要说出你的名字作为蜂鸣器。好的。好的，布拉布拉，当黑斯廷斯战役……杰森。你有什么？抱歉。1940年。
The Battle of the Hastings, this Norman King
was the conqueror.
William the Conqueror.
Okay, I blew that question. Ready?
Here we go.
This American car company...
By the way, 1066.
Yes, 1066.
黑斯廷斯战役，这位诺曼国王是征服者。威廉征服者。好的，我搞砸了那个问题。准备好了吗？我们开始吧。这家美国汽车公司……顺便说一句，1066年。是的，1066年。
This American car company ceased production in 2004.
This American what?
This American car company ceased production in 2004, but was part of GM.
Yeah, I know what it is.
Jason.
Olsmobile.
Yes, Jason Bateman's on the board.
Oh, wow.
这家美国汽车公司在2004年停止生产。这家美国什么？这家美国汽车公司在2004年停止生产，但它是通用汽车的一部分。是啊，我知道是什么。杰森。奥兹莫比尔。是的，杰森·贝特曼上榜了。哦，哇。
How do you know that?
Name another Mark's brother besides Groucho or Harpo.
Yeah.
Sean.
Groucho, Harpo, and
You were in the fucking movie
Richard.
No, that was the three stooges.
你怎么知道的？除了格劳乔或哈波，再说出一个马克思兄弟的名字。是啊。肖恩。格劳乔，哈波，还有你当时在那个该死的电影里，理查德。不，那是三个臭皮匠。
No, wait, it starts with a P, right?
Does it start with the P?
There's a C, a G, and a Z.
Zpo.
Zippo.
That's right.
Looking for Chico, Gummo, or Zepo.
The eastern region of Canada,
不，等等，它以P开头，对吧？它以P开头吗？有一个C，一个G，和一个Z。泽波。齐波。没错。我在找奇科、古莫或泽波。加拿大的东部地区，
the eastern region of Canada
consists of three provinces
and is known as what?
is known as the...
Commonwealth,
Jason Commonwealth.
No, no, no, no, no.
In the... Maritimes.
加拿大的东部地区由三个省组成，被称为是什么？被称为……联邦，杰森，联邦。不，不，不，不，不。在……海洋省份。
Yes.
Who was the 10th U.S. President?
Oh, God.
Jason!
Yes.
Lincoln.
McKinley.
No.
是的。谁是第10任美国总统？哦，天哪。杰森！是的。林肯。麦金莱。不。
John Tyler.
This actress has won more Emmys
than any other actor.
Jason.
Yes.
Is it Julie Louis-Dreyfus?
It is Julie Libby Dreyfus.
Isaac Newton, Charles Dickens,
约翰·泰勒。这位女演员获得的艾美奖比任何其他演员都多。杰森。是的。是朱莉·路易斯-德莱弗斯吗？是朱莉·路易斯-德莱弗斯。艾萨克·牛顿，查尔斯·狄更斯，
and Oliver Cromwell are buried in one.
London landmark.
Jason, it is the big church, the big cathedral, the big...
Westminster Abbey.
Boom.
Two more.
This man is the NHL's all-time leading score.
Sean.
和奥利弗·克伦威尔都埋在一个地方。伦敦地标。杰森，那是大教堂，大教堂，大……威斯敏斯特教堂。砰。还有两个。这个人是NHL历史上的得分王。肖恩。
Wayne Grisky.
Jason, Wayne Griskin.
No, it's Ovechkin.
No, score of goals.
Score, I was including points.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
I knew it was Oveston.
韦恩·格雷茨基。杰森，韦恩·格雷茨基。不，是奥维契金。不，进球得分。得分，我包括了积分。哦，好的。抱歉。我知道是奥维契金。
Most goals.
Sorry.
Last one.
Infant insects are called nymphs or small bugs.
Jason.
infant instex are called
or larvae.
Larva is correct.
进球最多。抱歉。最后一个。昆虫幼体被称为若虫或小虫子。杰森。昆虫幼体被称为或幼虫。幼虫是正确的。
Nice job, guys.
You guys got the majority of those right.
God, that's so cool that three of us
could get 20% of them right.
Welcome to SmartList.
Yeah, no shit.
Oh, my God.
Well, what's the name of that podcast there?
干得好，伙计们。你们大多数都答对了。天哪，我们三个人能答对20%真是太酷了。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。是啊，废话。哦，天哪。好吧，那个播客叫什么名字？
That podcast, Jason,
and thank you for asking us.
It's called Funny You Ask.
Oh, Funny You Ask.
That seems like a tune-in.
And you just had our friend,
you just had our mutual friend,
Adam Pally, on there,
那个播客，杰森，谢谢你问我们。它叫《Funny You Ask》。哦，《Funny You Ask》。那看起来像是一个值得收听的节目。你刚刚邀请了我们的朋友，我们的共同朋友，亚当·帕利，
who hosts a podcast for us.
Which I love with him and Gavris.
Yeah.
What's that one called?
Cross-plug.
Staying alive.
And it's a smartless media podcast.
他为我们主持一个播客。我喜欢他和加夫里斯一起主持的那个。那个叫什么名字？交叉推广。Staying Alive。是的，这是一个SmartLess Media播客。
Check it wherever you get your podcast.
Yeah.
With Gabris and Adam Pally.
Adam Palli is so fucking funny.
He is.
He is so fucking funny that dude.
He is a great guest.
He is so fucking funny that dude,
在任何你获取播客的地方查看它。是的。和加夫里斯还有亚当·帕利一起。亚当·帕利太他妈搞笑了。他是。他是真的太他妈搞笑了，那个家伙。他是个很棒的嘉宾。他太他妈搞笑了，那个家伙，
isn't he?
He said,
I was asking him.
what would you do if the Knicks could win the championship?
And I named a bunch of things.
Like, would you change your middle name to Stalin?
He was like, yes.
Yes, I said.
不是吗？他说，我当时在问他。如果尼克斯队能赢得冠军，你会做什么？我列举了一堆事情。比如，你会把你的中间名改成斯大林吗？他说，是的。是的，我说。
I was like, would you,
every time you turn on the TV to the rest of your life,
it's only kill Tony.
He's like, yes.
The one thing he said he wouldn't do is give up chicken parm.
Yeah, I saw that.
I can't, I can't give up chicken.
I'm sorry, I just cute.
我说，你会，余生每次打开电视，都只能看《Kill Tony》吗？他说，是的。他唯一说他不会做的事就是放弃鸡肉帕尔马干酪。是啊，我看到了。我不能，我不能放弃鸡肉。抱歉，我只是……
Now, do you have a co-host on your show?
No, it's all me, man.
It's solo.
Wow.
It's once a week?
It's once a week.
And I write all the questions for my guest.
It's one hour.
现在，你的节目有联合主持人吗？不，全是我，伙计。是单人。哇。一周一次？一周一次。我为我的嘉宾写所有的问题。是一个小时。
You do all your own questions.
I write the questions for the guests.
And I really love doing that.
It's a fun way to kind of like get into their head a little bit.
And then my producer, Annabel, writes the questions that the guest asks me because I also want to do a podcast where I answer questions.
But that's still like a lot of work that you're doing.
Considering all the shit that you're doing, you're writing running point, you're EPing that show.
you're doing the studio,
你做你自己的所有问题。我为嘉宾写问题。我真的很喜欢这样做。这是一种进入他们大脑的有趣方式。然后我的制片人，安娜贝尔，写嘉宾问我的问题，因为我也想做一个我回答问题的播客。但考虑到你正在做的所有那些破事，你正在写《Running Point》，你在做那个节目的执行制片人，你在做《The Studio》，
you're doing this podcast,
you're running around and doing all this.
Like, how the fuck?
You got an Adderall addiction?
I have a minor speed addiction
that we're trying to kick right now.
Cut this.
Let's get this.
你在做这个播客，你到处跑，做所有这些。到底怎么做到的？你有阿德拉尔成瘾吗？我有一个轻微的速度成瘾，我们现在正试图戒掉。剪掉这个。让我们得到这个。
Can I get a number?
With the podcast and the movies
and the being a father and everything else,
when do you slow down?
What do you do to slow down?
Yoga.
When Jason was saying I like to watch TV,
我能得到一个数字吗？有了播客和电影，还有作为父亲和其他一切，你什么时候慢下来？你做什么来慢下来？瑜伽。瑜伽。当杰森说我喜欢看电视时，
that's like my favorite thing to do.
It's like at the end of the day
is to watch like,
What's your favorite?
Is it reality TV?
Something dumb?
The only reality TV, not too much.
We just finished beef season two.
那是我最喜欢做的事。就像在一天结束时看，你最喜欢什么？是真人秀吗？一些愚蠢的东西？唯一的真人秀，不多。我们刚看完《怒呛人生》第二季。
Sure.
I like watching good TV shows as much as big a comment.
And the we is, is that the girlfriend or the wife?
That's the wife.
The girlfriend does not like TV.
The girlfriend wants to go out to nightclothes.
Yeah, she wants to take her out to nightclub.
She likes bottle service.
当然。我喜欢看好的电视节目，就像大评论一样。那个“我们”是，是女朋友还是妻子？那是妻子。女朋友不喜欢电视。女朋友想去夜店。是啊，她想带她去夜店。她喜欢瓶装服务。
You know, my wife and I...
She actually works at the club and does the bottle service.
Of course.
I don't know if you guys had this with your wife where my wife does want to go to bed
like earlier and earlier.
Yeah, she worked for a while.
And so there's some nights where it's like 8.52 and she's like, should we just go to bed?
And it's like this, it's like a push and pull.
你知道，我和我妻子……她实际上在俱乐部工作，做瓶装服务。当然。我不知道你们和你们的妻子是否有这种情况，我妻子确实想越来越早睡觉。是啊，她工作了一段时间。所以有些晚上，大概8点52分，她说，我们要不要直接去睡觉？就像这样，就像一种推拉。
We're like, no, we have to watch like 46 minutes of a TV show right now.
But what about, why can't, but you're not watching the TV shows in bed?
We don't, we did not put a TV in our bed.
That's smart.
It's terrible for your sleep.
Shut up.
I didn't either.
You both keeping the sex alive by no, yeah.
我们就像，不，我们现在必须看46分钟的电视节目。但是为什么，为什么不能，但你不是在床上看电视节目吗？我们没有，我们没有在床上放电视。那很聪明。这对你的睡眠很糟糕。闭嘴。我也没有。你们俩通过不，是啊，保持性生活活跃。
TV in there.
This is bullshit.
But so you're watching, by the way, that Beef Season 2,
can I just a shout out, obviously, Chuck Arnett,
but Carrie Mulligan.
Yeah.
The great Carrie Mulligan.
电视在里面。这简直是胡扯。但所以你在看，顺便说一句，那个《怒呛人生》第二季，我能打个招呼吗，显然，查克·阿内特，还有凯瑞·穆里根。是的。伟大的凯瑞·穆里根。伟大的凯瑞·穆里根。
Carrie Mulligan is the most underrated actor of our generation.
She's really good.
She is.
And Carrie's great.
I fucking love her.
I will say, though, that always sounds like a bat,
like that always sounds like a backhand compliment.
I will say to those who know what they're talking about,
凯瑞·穆里根是我们这一代最被低估的演员。她真的很好。她是。而且凯瑞很棒。我他妈爱她。不过，我得说，那听起来总像是一个反向的赞美。我会对那些知道他们在说什么的人说，
she is not underrated.
They're talking playing about her.
I just mean she should be lauded.
There should just be permanent billboards of her,
not even promoting a movie, just because she's...
I agree with you.
You should buy some, take them out.
I will.
她没有被低估。他们正在谈论她。我只是说她应该受到赞扬。应该有她的永久广告牌，甚至不是为了宣传电影，只是因为她是……我同意你的看法。你应该买一些，把它们拿出来。我会的。
I don't know if Marcus will, her husband will love it.
He might think that, you know what I mean?
It's a little strange.
It's a little bunch.
Anyway.
Hey, yeah, we are at hour one.
I know we're at hour, but I just...
Let's get to our first question.
我不知道马库斯会不会，她的丈夫会喜欢它。他可能会认为，你懂我的意思吗？这有点奇怪。这有点……总之。嘿，是的，我们已经一小时了。我知道我们已经一小时了，但我只是……让我们进入我们的第一个问题。
I love fucking Ike.
I just love hanging out with Mike.
I was so excited.
I said to Sean before, we were FaceTiming before,
you know, the core part of SmartList for FaceTiming before,
just Sean and me.
And I was saying, he was saying, is your guest good?
I said, oh, our guest is so good.
我他妈爱艾克。我只是喜欢和迈克待在一起。我太兴奋了。我之前对肖恩说，我们在FaceTime之前，你知道，SmartLess的核心部分在FaceTime之前，只是肖恩和我。我说，他在说，你的嘉宾好吗？我说，哦，我们的嘉宾太好了。
We just want to hang out and laugh and we'll do it.
Like, that's exactly right.
Do you have any questions, Will?
No, fuck no, I do.
You don't, do you?
I had a bunch.
Like, what's a note that you've gotten as an actor or a writer
that really change how you put your work?
我们只是想待在一起笑，我们会做到的。就像，那完全正确。你有什么问题吗，威尔？不，去他妈的，我有。你没有，对吧？我有一堆。比如，作为演员或作家，你得到过什么真正改变你工作方式的建议吗？
You collaborate with a lot of comedic voices.
What do you think makes a collaboration?
Who fucking cares?
This is the hang.
This is it.
This is the show.
Did you J.O. today?
你和很多喜剧声音合作。你认为什么造就了合作？谁他妈在乎？谁他妈在乎？这就是挂机。这就是它。这就是节目。你今天自慰了吗？
Let's just say I'm in a hotel room by myself.
Nuff said.
I, first of all, when does season through the studio come out because I can't wait?
That's going to come on next March, I believe.
Fuck all.
March 2027?
Wow.
Takes them that long to cut it together?
我们只能说我一个人在酒店房间里。不用多说。我，首先，当《The Studio》第三季出来时，因为我等不及了？那应该在明年三月出来，我相信。去他妈的。2027年三月？哇。花那么长时间剪辑在一起？
Fucking, what's up with Rogan and fucking Evan?
What are they doing?
Man, they're smoking dobies, man.
I know.
There's guys smoking the grass.
I bought one of, I told us, I bought one of Siss, his standing asterase.
No, I bought two of them.
And I sent him a pick and I said, hey, I'm supporting the cost.
该死的，罗根和埃文怎么了？他们在做什么？伙计，他们在抽大麻，伙计。我知道。那些家伙在抽草。我买了一个，我告诉过我们，我买了塞斯的一个立式烟灰缸。不，我买了两个。我给他发了一张照片，我说，嘿，我支持这个事业。
As an investor, I say thank you.
Oh, no shit.
Yeah, a little bit.
Fucking, what, you guys want to cut me a deal?
I fucking paid retail on the fucking website, dude.
I only invest in my friends companies.
We had no money in the market, no mutual funds, no Roth IRA.
I just invest in my friend's small business.
作为投资者，我说谢谢。哦，没开玩笑。是啊，一点点。该死的，什么，你们想给我一个折扣吗？我他妈在网站上付了零售价，伙计。我只投资我朋友的公司。我们没有钱在市场上，没有共同基金，没有罗斯个人退休账户。我只是投资我朋友的小生意。
That is so.
What's your email?
I'm going to send you a prospectus on something.
It's an old email.
It's dumbass Ike at AOL.
I got to show it for myriad reasons.
You're four minutes over, Will.
I know, I know.
那真是。你的邮箱是什么？我要给你发一份关于某事的招股说明书。这是一个旧邮箱。是笨蛋艾克@AOL。我有很多原因要展示它。你超时四分钟了，威尔。我知道，我知道。
I just want to say, I love having you.
I love that you, I love that the rest of the world appreciates
what a fucking great, funny dude you are increasingly.
And I've loved watching the success you've had with the studio.
I'm just fucking always rooting for you as you reach these crazy heights.
and everybody, when the studio came out...
You said it earlier.
I light up every time I see you.
我只是想说，我喜欢有你。我喜欢你，我喜欢全世界越来越欣赏你是一个多么他妈伟大、有趣的家伙。我喜欢看你在《The Studio》中取得的成功。我只是他妈的一直为你加油，当你达到这些疯狂的高度时。而且每个人，当《The Studio》出来时……你刚才说了。每次看到你，我都感到振奋。
100%.
You always have a great vibe
and then now you've taken to the next level
and everybody's like,
have you, people are like,
have you seen Ike Barrenholtz
on the fucking studio?
He's so fucking funny.
100%。你总是有一种很棒的氛围，然后现在你把它提升到了一个新的水平，每个人都像，你有，人们就像，你看过艾克·巴林霍尔茨在《The Studio》里吗？他太他妈搞笑了。
You're so fucking good.
And aside from all that,
you get hired over and over
because you're normal and easy and kind
and a good person.
You are.
Aside from all the talent.
你太他妈好了。除了所有这些，你一次又一次地被录用，因为你正常、随和、善良，是一个好人。你是。你是。除了所有的天赋。
It is true.
If you're listening out there
to our listener,
And you've got a script.
If you got a script,
Ike is the guy to send it to.
Give me the email one more time.
He'll put his name on it.
这是真的。如果你在听，对我们的听众。而且你有一个剧本。如果你有一个剧本，艾克是发送给他的那个人。再给我一次邮箱。他会把他的名字写在上面。
I might not be the best actor or the funniest actor,
but I'm on time.
And I'm respectful.
And that is all that matters.
You are truly, for our listener,
I will say truly,
you're one of the fucking great good dudes out there.
And I really mean that.
我可能不是最好的演员或最有趣的演员，但我很准时。而且我很尊重人。而这才是最重要的。对于我们的听众，我得说，你真的是他妈的伟大的好人之一。我是真心的。
This is a guess.
This is a bucket list thing from you guys.
Talk about a performance.
What a guy.
This guy.
Take another bow.
Ike Fadden holds.
The one and only.
这是一个猜测。这是你们的一个愿望清单。谈谈表演。真是个家伙。这个家伙。再鞠个躬。艾克·巴林霍尔茨。独一无二。
Thank you, Ike, for joining us, my friend.
Give our love to everybody over there on your cast that you guys are doing the Baptist
with, tell them we say hi, we love you guys, and we love you.
Amazing, love you guys.
Hurry home.
Thanks, Mike.
Bye, everybody.
Bye, Mike.
谢谢你，艾克，谢谢你加入我们，我的朋友。代我们向你们节目组的每一个人问好，告诉他们我们向他们问好，我们爱你们，我们也爱你。太棒了，爱你们。早点回家。谢谢，迈克。再见，各位。再见，迈克。
I love that, dude.
That's one of those fellas that I have not yet worked with, and I'm not happy about it.
You know, and you know who else?
Like, you know, like Seth, Evan, Judd Apatow.
Like, I've never been, never been included in that group ever.
No one's ever, you know, said, hey, won't you come on over and play?
Play, play a little bit.
我喜欢这样，伙计。我喜欢这样，伙计。那是还没和我合作过的家伙之一，对此我不太高兴。你知道，还有谁吗？比如，你知道，像塞斯、埃文、贾德·阿帕图。我从来没有，从来没有被纳入那个圈子。从来没有人说，嘿，你不想过来一起玩玩吗？玩玩，玩一点点。
Now stop.
No, stop for a second.
Take a beat.
And let's look at ourselves, Jason.
Let's look at ourselves for a second.
What's my part?
What is your role in it?
What is my part in it?
停下。不，停一下。缓一缓。让我们审视一下自己，杰森。让我们审视一下自己。我的责任是什么？你在其中扮演什么角色？我在其中扮演什么角色？
Hang on, let me get a mirror.
Let me get a mirror.
Don't get one of those true mirrors.
What's a true mirror?
Have you ever seen those where it's not even just a reflex like it kind of sees like what the world sees of you?
It's just inverted.
It's inverted.
等等，让我拿面镜子。让我拿面镜子。别拿那种“真实之镜”。别拿那种“真实之镜”。什么是“真实之镜”？你见过那种不是简单的反射，而是能看到别人眼中你的样子的镜子吗？它只是反转了。它是反转的。
It's scary a.
Wait, really?
It's different that you just your face is flipped the other way around?
Yeah, you look.
Yes.
Have you never done it?
I think the iPhone, if you reverse the camera, is that's the way people see you.
I don't know.
那太可怕了。等等，真的吗？只是你的脸被翻转过来了吗？是的，你看。是的。你从来没试过吗？我想iPhone如果反转摄像头，那就是别人看你的方式。我不知道。
No, you just see the room you're in.
I don't know.
Yeah, but I mean, that's the perspective of people looking at you.
Oh, you're in luck.
MIT just called.
they have an opening.
Like what I'm looking at right now
on this Zoom, I'm assuming that is
不，你只是看到了你所在的房间。我不知道。是的，但我的意思是，那是别人看你的视角。哦，你走运了。麻省理工学院刚打电话来，他们有个空缺。就像我现在在Zoom上看到的，我假设那是
the perspective that you would have
if you were sitting across from me, right?
Because the camera's in front of me.
Yeah, yeah, I guess so, yeah.
I'm not sure, can we get Tyson,
Neil DeFeson on the blower, please?
This is so depressing.
Wait, Sean's going to, here he comes.
如果你坐在我对面时会有的视角，对吧？因为摄像头在我面前。是的，是的，我想是这样。我不确定，我们能请泰森，尼尔·德格拉塞·泰森来解释一下吗？这太让人沮丧了。等等，肖恩要，他来了。
I'm just going to see his eyes.
Oh, here it is.
Scotty just DMed him.
Just DMed him a little bye.
No, no, let me see.
Oh, okay.
I'm looking up something else, has nothing to do with.
Scrolling, scrolling.
我只是想看看他的眼睛。哦，在这儿。斯科蒂刚给他发了私信。刚给他发了个小小的再见。不，不，让我看看。哦，好吧。我在查别的东西，和这没关系。滚动，滚动。
Do you remember the...
Oh, hey, do you guys...
Hey, this is a weird thing I was just thinking about.
Do you remember that Beatles song or Paul McCartney's song
where he's singing about a bird or something?
Oh.
Blackbird?
你还记得那个……哦，嘿，你们……嘿，我刚才在想一件奇怪的事。你还记得那首披头士的歌，或者保罗·麦卡特尼的歌，他唱的是关于一只鸟什么的吗？哦。哦。《黑鸟》？
Yeah.
Talk about it.
Talk about it out of left fucking fields.
Yeah.
That's Wrigley Field.
And when the...
And when the ball goes out of Wrigley Field,
是的。说说看。突然冒出来的话题。是的。那是瑞格利球场。那是瑞格利球场。当球飞出瑞格利球场时，
you say what to it?
You say, bye-bye ball.
Bye-bye, Blackbird.
Hey, you guys, where did you go?
Blackbird, bye.
Hey, bye.
Smartless.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by
你会对它说什么？你会说，再见球。再见，黑鸟。嘿，你们，你们去哪儿了？黑鸟，再见。嘿，再见。《Smartless》。《Smartless》是100%有机且由手工精心制作的，制作人是
Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico,
and Michael Grand Terry.
Smart less.
罗伯·阿姆贾夫、本内特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰·特里。《Smartless》。